hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American action thriller
film called plane spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with a pilot rushing
through the airport as he is running
late for his flight Brody Torrance
what a name was forced to work his
holiday runs out of Singapore after
beating an intoxicated customer who got
into an altercation with several flight
attendants as he tries to get through
security to make it to the aircraft he
receives a call from his daughter whom
he plans to meet in Hawaii after he is
done with the flight it is New Year's
Eve and his daughter is worried that he
wouldn't make it in time to spend the
New Year together however he assures her
that he will be there hoping there won't
be any delays being home for Christmas
on time is for losers Brody Torrance
makes it for New Year's fortunately he
reaches his aircraft in time where he
learns from his co-pilot Dell that the
flight officer has not yet made a visit
the two pilots then get to know each
other as Dell shows Torrance the bad
weather situation that they will face on
their way as they Chad the flight
officer enters and informs them that
Trailblazer 119 their aircraft would set
off for Tokyo with 14 passengers
Torrance at that moment expresses his
concern about the weather and suggests
an alternative route for the flight that
would help them avoid the weather but
the flight officer Cuts him off and
tells him that the weather might clear
by the time they reach there and taking
the other route would add more hours in
addition doing that for an almost empty
flight is just bothersome unable to
oppose the two pilots just agree next a
flight attendant enters the deck and
introduces herself as Bonnie before
informing Torrance that he was needed in
the jet way with that he leaves for the
jet way where he is met by police
officers with a handcuffed person the
man's name is Louis Gaspar and he is
being extradited on charges of homicide
Torrance is concerned that a handcuffed
felon will make the passengers uneasy so
he tells the officer to keep away from
them the officer named Knight agrees and
takes the seat at the end of the plane
with Gaspar shaking off the uneasiness
Torrance meets the other flight
attendants Isabella who he recognizes uh
did we and Maria they then greet the
passengers with the New Year's greeting
many sorts of passengers are seen among
whom are a Sinclair a short-tempered
businessman and a bothersome some couple
who complain about the plane's condition
Torrance tells them that the aircraft is
fine trying to assure them of their
safety another group of passengers
consists of Katie who came with brie a
social media influencer AKA a useless
human being they seem to be the original
owner of the seat Knight and Gaspar had
taken thrilled by them they choose a
different seat as instructed by Maria
and later try to snap a picture of
Gaspar to share their experience Gaspar
notices it and instantly tells them not
to with everyone settled with their seat
belts secured Torrance briefs the flight
over the intercom followed by a
Southwest Airline grade joke and takes
off the flight everything goes smoothly
as the flight attendants serve the
passengers while the pilots talk to each
other about their families however
things start to take a turn when they
meet the storm they had expected to come
across Torrance alerts everyone to
fasten their seatbelts and contacts the
air traffic control to notify them of
the situation but receives no response
as they fly ahead they get deeper into
the storm suddenly a flash of lightning
strikes the plane shaking the whole
aircraft and panicking the passengers
leaving Dell in control Torrance goes to
the cabin to calm the passengers down
and sees a scene with the passengers
belongings lying on the way that fell
due to the strike he helps the
attendants pick them up and tells
everyone that it was just the weather
Sinclair bashes him for not controlling
the plane well can't you control
lightning aren't you Zeus No that's
Russell Crowe so Torrance just ignores
him and tells the flight attendants to
not let anyone unfasten their seatbelts
unfortunately the plane is struck again
making Torrance lose his balance and hit
his head causing it to bleed trying his
best he reaches the deck and takes over
the flight with the entire power and
communication cut off and a big
rainstorm ahead the pilots try their
best to find a way to get a signal they
try every possible way but see no
solution knowing that the battery won't
last more than a few minutes they make
an impromptu decision to land the plane
anywhere possible Bonnie informs
everyone in the Flight of the electrical
malfunction and slowly commands them to
fasten their seat belts and not leave
their seats no matter what with eyes on
the gyro the pilots do their best to
find ways to land while the attendants
try their best to keep themselves and
the passengers in place that's when
officer Knight's phone falls from his
hands and lands on the floor the
attendants Panic at what he might do and
continuously warn him but he decides to
be ignorant and goes to pick it up
Isabella as an attendant can't help but
go save him but another strike shakes
the whole plane and instantly shoots
them off killing them right then and
there a horrified Bonnie warns everyone
to stay in their seats no matter what
and after witnessing what happened to
the policeman they don't dare to move
again inside the cockpit the pilots
finally find a suitable place to land
but they only have three minutes before
the engines run out with the clock
ticking over their heads they put all
their effort to go down just when the
plane is about to crash Torrance sees a
road and turns the plane in its
Direction with a lot of difficulties and
the blades of the plane cutting through
the forest trees the captain manages to
make a successful Landing everyone
celebrates that they are finally on the
ground and figure out that they might be
on an island somewhere in the
Philippines since the airplane hasn't
stabilized yet the passengers are asked
to immediately get off of it through the
emergency exit Dell goes down first
followed by all the other passengers
Bonnie who is checking on the bodies of
the Dead is called by Torrance to get
off by Dawn everyone is off the plane
safe and relieved on the contrary the
CEO of the airlines sets a meeting about
the Trailblazer 119's missing along with
Scarsdale a former Special Forces
officer who leads the rescue effort
Scarsdale upon knowing that the flight
officer didn't let Torrance take the
other route calls him out for doing so
they come to learn that the plane signal
was last received in Manila but was soon
disconnected the officers discuss all
the possible ways to find its location
in the next scene Bonnie asks torrent
about Gaspar and handsome the keys to
his handcuffs which she found while
evacuating the plane Torrance and Dell
go over the map trying to locate where
they might have possibly landed and find
out it is Jolo Island upon hearing the
name Dell freezes he informs Torrance
that it is an island ruled by heavily
armed anti-malicious who are known for
killing and robbing Torrance decides to
hide this from the passengers to not
cause a state of panic instead he tells
them that they might have landed in the
Philippines and that they will try to
find a way to ask for help he then helps
them set up a tent outside Sinclair
being the man that he is protests that
they stay inside the plane to which
Torrance replies that staying inside the
plane was a big no given the power cut
and the heat the passengers take
torrance's side and tell Sinclair that
he should just appreciate what the
pilots did hey piss off Sinclair
thereafter Torrance and Dell go to check
if they can get the power back on
however they fail to do so Torrance goes
inside the plane and wraps the dead
bodies driven by his curiosity about
Gaspar he checks the officer's bag and
gets off after getting his gun he
changes into a different shirt as Zell
packs his bag with some water it turns
out that he wants to go find help and
take Gaspar with him after informing all
the passengers that it might take some
time for the rescue to reach there
Torrance tells them his plan and uncuffs
Gaspar the two then set off to look for
help back in the headquarters in New
York everyone is still looking for Clues
but they find none given the little
information that they could be in the
Philippines Scarsdale uses every
connection he has to help the people out
at last the mercenary Black Ops are
called in for the rescue mission going
deep into the forest Torrence questions
Gaspar about his intentions because he
found a pocket knife while going through
his belongings however a mysterious
Gaspar gives him no information then we
are introduced to the chief of the
anti-malisha junmar he is informed by
one of the villagers of the plane
landing furthermore he tells them that
it landed near the mines June Mar
concludes that it could not be the Army
since his spies didn't give him any such
information Torrance on the other hand
is alone now because Gaspar fled Midway
he reaches a warehouse where he is able
to make a call after fixing a few
circuits he calls the Airlines and to
notifies them them of the whole
situation but the person on the line
doesn't understand him well before the
line gets cut Torrance then calls his
daughter Daniella who is worried sick by
now she picks up and learns everything
from him he then tells her to get the
information through to the airlines that
they were on Jolo Island you only live
once Daniela so get me the hell out of
here all of a sudden he gets attacked
from behind he tries his best to break
free and after a long while of
struggling Torrance manages to knock the
attacker down simultaneously he hears
gunshots and gets his gun ready with
footsteps approaching near he meets
Gaspar who then hands him a rifle while
on their way down Torrance sees a bunch
of dead bodies of people who Gaspar
killed they then find a camera with a
video through which they learn that
foreigners were robbed in that place
before them worried that the same will
happen to the passengers the duo rushes
to them in the robber's van the
passengers happily stand up hearing the
sound of the vehicles but soon get
thrown off by the gunshots knowing it's
not the rescue that they had hoped for
Torrance and Gaspar reached their just
just in time as the robbers are taking
over the passengers they forcefully take
the passenger list from Bonnie and ask
for torrents but no one tells them who
he is just then a girl tries to escape
and is instantly shot her boyfriend
cries for help but he gets mercilessly
killed too the terrified passengers are
then evacuated Torrance tries to
interfere and help them but Gaspar holds
him back knowing that going in front of
the robbers is the captain would be
foolish June Mar orders two of his men
to take everything from the passengers
that could give them money Gaspar and
Torrance then capture him and force
information out of him they then find
out that they are headed to dandelit
Village but fail to get more information
than that Torrance then goes inside the
plane again and locates The Village on
the map and leaves a message for the
Rescue Team having discovered that Dell
somehow managed to fix the Electric
System consequently back in the
headquarters Scarsdale hires the
mercenary Black Ops to go to the island
after confirming the information with
Daniela Torrance and Gaspar on the other
hand reached the village where the
passengers are held hostage slowly
eliminate donating the robbers one after
another they meet the rest of the
passengers thankfully with only a man
guarding them the duo successfully frees
them and takes them to a boss but
escaping would only alert the rest so
Torrance goes to distract the robbers
putting his life at risk he greets the
chief and acts as though he doesn't know
who he is the act ends up getting him
hit at that moment the assigned team
Fires at the robbers and ends up killing
a lot of them it turns out that they
were fast to reach the plane and catch
up with the passengers with the help of
the message soon they safely reach the
bus along with Torrance June Mar is
enraged by the situation and orders his
remaining men to go to the plane during
the ride Torrance learns that no Rescue
Team would come there until the next 24
hours shellback asks for his help
instead they reached the plane where
Torrance asks everyone to trust him one
last time and Boards the plane since it
was the only way they can make it out of
there and everyone agrees Torrence asks
the rescue team to help him buy some
time until he can fix something right
then junma arrives and attacks hurting
one of the passenger with a lot of
gunfire both parties try their best to
overpower the other a while later it is
time for Torrance to enter the plane as
everyone else backs him up he makes a
run and gets in despite getting shot in
one of his legs he informs the
headquarters about flying the plane
which Hampton refuses but Scarsdale
supports who the hell is Hampton anyway
while the pilots and remaining crew do
everything they can inside the plane
shellback and Gaspar are still out
fighting Gaspar finds the bag of money
the mercenary Zone while trying to
recoil the rifle as it is time to set
off everyone but Gaspar gets in Gaspar
leaves with a bag of money and shellback
just watches him do so meanwhile junma
and one of his men are still trying
their best to stop them June Mars man
picks up an rgf to hit the plane but
Gaspar kills him off just in time saving
the plane Torrance sees the missile go
off in a different direction and feels
relieved but is again Disturbed as June
Mar picks up the rgf ready to shoot the
plane junmar has his car parked in front
of the plane which he thinks will stop
it however Torrance who has no plans to
oblige takes off the plane right through
them this is Jolo with the help of the
air traffic that is finally connected
via the rescue team they find an airport
near just reachable with the plane's
remaining capacity Torrance successfully
lands the plane in a place where there
are no more attackers this time he is
congratulated by the Applause of the
passengers finally everyone gets off the
plane the movie ends as Torrance gets
off after them as a hero who saved many
lives subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching